the Joe Rogan experience Action Bronson
de la show where he gets high and watch
ancient aliens I was trying to do it
last season but every time they were
doing it I was busy doing something else
and I couldn't do it dude he's the less
they get high and watch ancient aliens
dude is the best and they set around on
a green screen that's a good TV
that's better than half of the other
[ __ ] that's actually that's fun and
new well it's fun for sure
look at me think about if you can have
some dude showing up at garage sales
trying to get the best deal you can't
have action proxy screen with his homies
getting blasted come on bro yeah
hilarious big body best right dude look
at his headset got that Tommy Tommy
Tommy Chong joints right here folks
look at look at look at the DJ alchemist
is sleeping on the far right he look at
him he's a good dude
action yeah he's this [ __ ] dudes this
[ __ ] let me see that let me see that
this is a Tommy Chong joint yeah he's
smoking a fat one but not like that
[ __ ]
this is ridiculous unless is the Tommy
Tong joint dropped down to that size you
never knew smile no I'm gonna keep it
forever he's a legend Tommy Chong is a
legend I used to listen to his albums
when I was a kid man for me to just even
be on a podcast with him was surreal I
just didn't want to waste his time I
just wanted to like be nice to him he's
that weird that big for him though
do you his neck while doesn't that make
you feel type of way where you like me
I'm a here older student he's like dude
I love your [ __ ] I'm happy and I'm happy
that Tommy Chong loves me because I love
him and Cheech was a kid man yeah those
guys were heroes you know like they were
ridiculous they made everything fun they
were silly yeah everything was off they
were getting high and it was silly and I
don't even get high when I loved them
when I loved when I was watching their
movies and I was a kid like up and smoke
what year was that
cuz up 78 77 say okay and find that out
and then find out what year big bamboo
came out cuz big bamboo was the album
that looked like rolling papers right
and they had a paper in there didn't
that yeah I think so I think there was a
giant piece but they did write 78 78 was
right
seventy-eight and then wait and then and
then in that album they they would later
put an actual piece of rolling paper in
there well the record sleeve was a
rolling usable rolling papers right
giganta's whittler than that promoting
illegal drugs
you think marijuana was a full-on
Schedule one drug schedule 1 schedule
172 was big bamboo oh wow a big bamboo
was before okay so I was yeah yeah yeah
there it is and there's the [ __ ]
rolling paper I was five years old look
I was born in 67 this was 72 so that's
the rolling paper wow they have a real
one look at the [ __ ] inside cover the
picture the two of them that is crazy
positive meaning is that picture yeah
that picture that's crazy before they
were together and that improv group he
was in when they were really young like
well right before that right that's
crazy is that what that's from it's
right before that oh wow if I could find
any engine these guys are still doing
shows still selling out here's the thing
Santino and Rogan in 2000 84 we're gonna
be taking our silver dog gonna be taking
our vitamins man
[Applause]